mais avant d'entamer ce tour d'europe
d'une europe qui doute partons pour
l'extrême orient pour le japon où notre
souris à nationale a versé une larme
elle espérait l'or aux championnats du
monde de patinage artistique
elle n'a eu que l'argent et a montré son
dépit avec un certain cran françois
korber sourya bien entendre son nom
la marche de la médaille d'or est trop
haute pour elle des larmes amères faire
le dans ses yeux
coup de théâtre au pied du podium sourya
refuse de monter sur la deuxième marche
l'officiel chargé de lui remettre la
médaille d'argent est décontenancé les
bravos de la poule se transforme en s'y
plaît finalement souri à fait contre
mauvaise fortune bon coeur et accepte
l'incident est clos
ou presque l'émotion sans doute aussi la
déception l'emporté à nouveau sourya ne
gardera que 12 secondes au cou sa
médaille d'argent
c'est alors que yuka sato label
patineuse japonaise médaille d'or vole
au secours de souria qui timidement
comme si cette première marche de
championne du monde lui était toujours
interdite essaie malgré tout de garder
l'esprit sportif sourya une saute
d'humeur à chiba au japon mais les
patineuses ont aussi un coeur et il peut
parfois être malheureux bave